hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the feeder World Cup
2019 it's the England versus Alexander
issue yesterday we've shown a game where
Greece had the white pieces and well
after that Queen to have three move dink
had a win with Bishop to d5 but it was
an extremely difficult move to calculate
over the board and well in the end the
game ended in a draw so this is there a
second classical game now dink has the
white pieces and we do have a photo of
the matchup but this is from yesterday's
game not this one that we're showing
where you've had the white pieces but
let's check it out nevertheless so this
is the photo they have it a nice
handshake before the start of the game
Greece was looking very smooth ding not
ironing out his shirt I like it you know
time spent ironing is less time that you
could spend analyzing your chess games
so definitely the correct approach so
without further ado let's check it out
ding with the white pieces opened the
width see for the English opening is on
the board with E 5 by 3 shook g3 and
Knight to f6 with Bishop to g2 Bishop to
c5 now and d3 with d5 already attacking
in the center C captures Knight captures
and now there are a couple of games
where Knight to f3 and Queen to a4 check
was played but nice the c3 binding is a
new move so incredible as it is but
already as of move 6 we have a
completely new game Grisha avoids the
trade with Knight back to b6 and Knight
to f3 ting is now ready to castle with
nice the c6 and the both players Castle
with castles biding classes by Grisha
and a3 preparing to put B for grief of
course prevents this with a 5 and now
Knight to a4 adding golfers afraid of
nice if you don't want to trade you will
either lose your dark square Bishop or
you will have your bone structure messed
up here if the bishop for example
retreats
so with Knight captures on a4 with Queen
captures on a4 and now Knight to d4
again offering yet another trade Knight
capture Sun before Bishop captures on d4
and here Bing has to figure out how to
develop his pieces he still has to get
the bishop into the game but how do you
get it into the game
without losing your beat upon welding
finds a very nice way he plays Bishop to
d2 as it turns out it's not all that
great to capture on b2 if you kept from
me - you get rook the b1 and now after
the bishop moves now you can just
capture on b7 so black didn't really
achieve all that much so here a great
place
c6 prevents this Bishop from capturing
on b7 for example in that line also
prepares to further expand on the Queen
side would be five but dink again with
III and now it's even worse the capture
on b2 for example if you capture now
route k2 and the bishop is trap you have
no retreat squares so after e3 girl goes
back with the best with Bishop to b6 and
now bush of the c3 finally dings Bishop
I is on a very nice diagonal well both
of the bishops are we've looked at EI by
grace of developing the rook and rook F
to D one being does the same will rush
up to b7 preparing to push the c5 pawn
with some discovery on the Queen and
rook 8c one now all things forces are
mobilized with h6 and h3 and now comes
Luke the b8 now you want to move the
bishop push b5 and we'll continue the
game depending on what white plays but
you do want to expand on the Queen side
we've roped the d2 a nice mini ROK lift
by dink and this allows not only
doubling on the D file but also doubling
on the C file if needed with Bishop to
c7 now preparing to push the beep on and
now d4 we have c5 with more pressure in
the center as the queen is now under
attack so the ding retreats that we have
Queen to c2 and now he captures on d4
with ecad person before and now c4 I
agree she prefers to keep the D file or
closed and also if the ding doesn't want
to put d5
this Bishop diagonal is also closed for
now so he doesn't want to allow b5 so he
pushes a for himself and now Bishop to
d6 agree ship makes a room for his Queen
on c7
we're group d2 d1 doubling up on the D
file now sorry not doubling up in the
default but rather rook
back to the one preparing rook to e1 to
trade rooks and along the e-file with b6
by black now the b7 point is no longer a
target and now look to e 1 as planned
with rook captures anyone with Czech
rook captures anyone and now Queen to c7
and here H for not keeping her pawn and
h3 to remain a target we've looked at a
eight offering afraid of yet another
rook and now Bishop to d5 so here
it's both players still with the bishop
pair both players are a queen a rook and
five points each so the position on the
board is is equal with rook captures
with Czech Bishop captures rook and now
Bishop to e6 as the c4 pawn is under
attack you do have to prevent it somehow
so Greece who finds the Bishop to e6
this does prevent the loss of the c4
pawn but then again you are also getting
your pawn structure messed up so dink
plays it with Bishop captures an e6 and
now F captures an e6 resulting in three
point islands for for greedy shook with
24 a nice centralizing move with the
Queen going after the e6 pawn so agree
should defends it with King to f7 and
now Girish was very low on time here
somewhere
I think he had last less than a minute
here and here thing it really has to
decide what to do here as the opponent
is very long time thing is like he still
has still has half an hour of time on
his clock and he has to decide what to
do it doesn't want to push d5
immediately does he want to play h5 grab
and grab more space on the Kings side
but he plays an even nicer move and it's
an even nicer move especially since your
opponent is a very long time
because if you play a forcing move then
your opponent has a force reply and then
he will just gain more time but the ding
plays Bishop the c3 and now he agree she
just has to find a move there is no
forcing line that he can just play so he
retreats with the Bishop Bishop to f8
and now comes d5 preparing to capture
here with check so Queen to d6 defending
now we have D captures on e6 with Czech
Queen captures on e6 and now comes Queen
to b7 which check King goes back to GA
and now the b6 pawn is pressured so ding
decides to pressure it again with Bishop
to d4 and here again which was all the
time very low on time and he has to
decide what to do here it's very hard to
defend the b6 pawn I mean you can defend
it for example if you place on Bishop c5
you get Queen g7 mate you don't want
something like this to happen so Greece
shock almost lost all of his time he had
three seconds on the clock when he
played Queen to f5 and it comes with the
idea that he he could maybe do some
checks for example queen b1 check
followed by Queen to e4 check if the b6
bone is captured and also it comes with
the idea that well if Bishop captures
then you can play Bishop to c5 would
attack on the f2 pawn and it doesn't
work good had a nice move here but it's
extremely hard to find especially with
three seconds on the clock there is a
way out of this position with King to h7
and now after wife captures the pawn for
example you could play Queen captures
and b6 but now you get Queen d7 and now
White Queen has too much on her hands
the White Queen cannot keep defending
the bishop here and also the a4 pawn so
black would simply win back the pawn but
you know that's when you have more time
on the clock to find such moves the girl
should play the Queen to f5 and now his
idea is yes if Bishop captures then you
can go back up the c5 with an attack on
the F do pawn and now if the bishops are
traded captures captures ding would be
up a pawn for example Queen b5 you offer
a queen trade but then angry she can
play Queen B for and here he could make
things difficult for ding as he would
have to look look some other way how to
proceed in this game because you cannot
trade here if you trade black is just
fast for you you push a 5 black pushes
c3 and you will end up cleaning with
check and of course now Grisha would be
completely winning so after the squinter
5 move ding didn't capture with the
bishop and of course he still doesn't
want to capture with the Queen he see he
sees a Queen to d7 so first he just
improves the position King to h7 he says
there's no way for Grisha to improve his
position with the constant threat of
on g7 you can't move your Bishop and the
Queen can't really do all that much at
the bishop nicely guards df2 pawn all
the time so everything is nicely
protected here with Queen to c2 by
critic and not now going after the e4
pawn thing okay now if you capture I
just capture on a4 but now dingos Queen
to d5 check with King to h7 and now
Queen to f7 a very nice move
the bishop is under attack and you
cannot move it if you move it you get
Queen captures g7 checkmate so the only
way to avoid losing the bishop is to
defend it so here a Grecian finds Queen
to d3 he says okay if you capture my
Bishop I'll capture your Bishop but now
ding still doesn't go after the pawn you
could capture it but ding still just
keeps everything you know as it is he
pushes the bishop back
Bishop to c3 he just keeps the tension
in the position now you still can't move
the bishop
otherwise you're getting checkmate it
and the only way for to continue playing
this game is to defend the bishop so he
plays Bishop to d6 but now then you got
exactly what he wanted the Queen had to
move and now the c4 pawn is free for
grabs here adding plays Bishop captures
on c4 so now he's up a pawn Grisha
played Queen to g6 and just to mention
Queen to d6 defending the bishop was the
group's 40th move so he reached on
control here he gained more time on the
clock but now he's down upon Queen
captures on c4 with Queen to g6 and here
ding just played Bishop to b4 he will
now again organize an attack against the
b6 pawn which will not be easily
defended and believe it or not it was in
this position on move 42 that Alexandria
should resigned the game and with this
resignation he is out of the Phaedo
World Cup whereas being proceeds to the
semi-finals
so if you're wondering about the quote
above the border why is there no who
said it ding actually said it I just
blocked it so you can see it there we
have it he said this in an interview
after the game he said that he is happy
about the result but he is not but maybe
who did not play so well because he was
in time trouble all the time so there
were there were ways out but with so
little time on the clock there it was
your
way of finding it so yeah here with
being down upon a very shook is very
convinced that ding will win this game
and he doesn't see himself having any
chance this year so he just resides not
hoping for link to fall for any tricks
but yeah I think advances to the
semifinals we'll see we'll see what
happens next
and yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it - tough break for for Sasha
but you know there can be only only one
in a match so I would like to thank
Paulo a lot now go for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual we can check - on
my previous video Sarah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day